the strongest of the strong in jutu kais
and the strongest sourcers of all time
will be broken down in this video and
even ranked at the end so make sure to
stay tuned for that use your six eyes to
locate and then smash that like button
if you enjoy seeing JSU kaisen videos
like this one on the channel and want to
keep them coming make this the video you
join the special grade fam if you
haven't already by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future dreu kaisen videos and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all so first up we
have Yuki tukumo who made her debut via
flashback and in an AE total flashback
no less she's further hyped for me
because she had such an impact on Toto
one of my favorite characters after
third grader Toto beat up a high
schooler with a bad attitude he was just
thinking that beating up a boring guy is
boring that's when Yuki showed up
congratulating him and asking the iconic
question what kind of girls are you into
at that point he had a feeling that he
wouldn't be bored for long then this
hyped up character shows up again during
chapter 76 during the Gojo and ghetto
flashback again she shows up and asks
this time ghetto what kind of girls he's
into soon enough she tells ghetto she is
special grade sorcerer Yuki tsukumo and
ghetto is shaking even sweating a bit
when he says you're the dot dot dot
clearly her reputation proceeds her and
she says yeah the no good special grade
who doesn't take on any missions and
just bums around overseas with a
response like that how could you not
love her that's the real question she
goes on to say that she hates Jutsu high
and then clarifies saying she doesn't
see eye to eye with the way the school
does things she says they treat the
symptoms while she wants to get to the
root cause Yuki doesn't want to exercise
curses she wants a world where curses
don't even exist since curses are formed
when cursed energy leaks from humans she
says there are two ways to eradicate
them one eradicate cursed energy from
all of humanity and two teach humans how
to control their cursed energy ghetto is
intrigued by number one but points out
that toi zenin was the only one for whom
cursed energy was completely eradicated
Yuki says cases like that of heavenly
restriction are few and far between so
her focus is on the second method of
teaching humans how to control their
cursed energy Yuki explains that
jiujitsu Sorcerers don't give birth to
curses excluding cases where Sorcerers
become curses after death the cursed
energy that leaks from them compared to
non Sorcerers is really low for
Sorcerers it flows heav within them in
general terms she says if every single
human became a jiutu sorcerer curses
would no longer be born and this really
gets to ghetto he says then why not kill
every non sorcerer she says it's an
option and that might be the easiest way
they could force evolve people and
create a situation where survival rests
on adapting to a sorcerer based society
using fear and danger as a catalyst
although ghetto maybe she says she's not
that crazy to try something like that
we'll get to this more when we disc
discuss fellow special grade ghetto
later on in the video but at this point
he was beginning to wonder if non
Sorcerers are worth fighting for she
eventually takes off saying as fellow
special grade Sorcerers her ghetto and
Gojo should get along she also tells him
not to worry about what happened with
the star plasma vessel since whether it
was another vessel or another vessel was
born Tangen stabilized she's the one
that told ghetto he'd eventually be the
one to decide his true feelings and path
despite being torn now so now we have a
sense of her personality and evolving
philosophy during chapter 130 we learned
that Toto learned how to use Simple
domain from Yuki the counter domain
technique that can neutralize a domain
expansions guaranteed hit function
another not her skill Yuki finally
confronts pseudo ghetto AKA kju and the
two explain how their philosophies
differ at this point Yuki says the next
stage of humanity lies in breaking away
from cursed energy while ancient
sorcerer and body snatcher Kaku says no
it lies in optimizing cursed energy Yuki
would rather have a peaceful world
without cursed Spirits while Kaku
obviously wants No Such Thing Kaku says
he thought she abandoned that method 12
years ago when toi zenan died and she
responds she was talking to ghetto but
oh well she answers anyway saying she
came back to original principles now
let's jump to when Yuki actually fought
Kaku it's definitely her most telling
fight to see how strong she actually is
after choso took a crack at him Yuki
came in thanking him and saying good
work big brother she told the exhausted
choso to leave the rest to her it's cool
she has that Goku energy and when she
shows up you just feel better and like
things will be okay will they actually
be okay though we have to wait and see
right away kenju points out that
although she's a special grade
headquarters keeps a tight liit on Intel
about her curse technique he couldn't
get any information from the higher ups
either so he decides it's best to keep
her at a distance that coming from
someone like Kaku is definitely a big
compliment At first she uses her
shikigami Garuda as as a cursed tool to
quickly deal with a special grade curs
Spirit released by kenju it's even
better that she attacks it by using guda
as a soccer ball or football Kaku is
shocked when he sees its power and
that's when Yuki explains its mass
pretty much star rage her technique
allows her to give virtual Mass to her
or guda in order to deliver devastating
destructive force she punches Kaku and
send him flying she breaks his bones in
the process too kinjaku points out it's
a concept that targets a cursed
technique Mass so overwhelming it
surpasses anything inside and outside
kinjaku puts together that the increased
Mass doesn't affect her because her
speed isn't decreased Yuki is quick
enough to realize from her attack that
Kaku must have a third curse technique
that involves gravity aside from his
curse manipulation and techniques that
allow him to transfer bodies both Kaku
and Yuki think to themselves this fight
is going to be a pain especially since
Kaku assumes she probably has an
expansion technique with with high
cursed energy output as a trump card
kenju then uses domain expansion womb
profusion the plan was for Yuki to use
Simple domain into buy time while Tangen
works on neutralizing kaku's domain but
we're quickly told they miscalculated
like sukuna in Shibuya Kaku pulled off
an amazing feat in which he opened his
domain and activated a technique without
closing the barrier so there is no outer
shell to remove the domain is also so
powerful it quickly strips Yuki of her
simple domain somehow Tangen does manage
to spell it but not before Kaku lands a
devastating hit on Yuki Kaku thinks it's
all over but he should know to expect
more from a special grade Sorcerer And
soon enough notices that her shikigami
is still there she gets up too Kaku
assumes she uses reversed curse
technique to heal while her shikigami
buys time and he also decides he'll
replenish his curse techniques but then
suddenly she appears in attacks he
blocks and asks why doesn't she heal and
she says because I don't want to end
quote man I love her character she has a
smile on her bloody face as she fights
in the middle of the hand-to-hand
fighting guda wraps around Kaku Kaku
thinks that Yuki is at her limit but
then choso comes in and Yuki makes guda
so heavy Kaku can't fully avoid the
bloodshot but Kaku is a beast to and
Spins his head to deflect the piercing
blood then Yuki kicks him but we're told
damage had already weakened star rage
otherwise Kaku would have been toast
right there nevertheless she and choso
keep on attacking Yuki uses reverse
curse technique to recharge but it
slowed down star rage and gave Kaku a
chance to temporarily Escape when ready
she uses G as a whip and devastates the
battlefield with the destructive power
but before they can land a lethal blow
Kaku replenishes his curse technique and
uses his aformentioned gravity powers to
bring down choso and the guda whip
before they can hit him Yuki in the
middle of battle mind U deduces that
that curse technique has a radius of 2
to 3 m from the sorcerer and continues
for 6 seconds in that interval she tries
to attack she goes in saying she's going
to win she punches him again and again
while she can knowing she won't get
another chance but then he catches her
arm and attacks with a tiny Uzumaki the
second attack goes straight through her
as kinjaku explains she doesn't feel
extra weight due to Star rage so while
her density increases her tensile
strength doesn't and tensile strength is
the ability of a material to withstand a
maximum amount of tensile stress without
failure in other words instead of her
body being pulled or stretched by the
attack distresses too much and it tears
right through her he then Stomps on her
separating her body into two halves Yuki
being the absolute monster she is even
grabs Kaku by the foot with an arm after
this happens she smiles saying star
rage's alterations in Mass don't affect
me but only up to a certain density if
there's no limit Kaku realizes that she
can create a black hole which possesses
extreme density and immense gravity
neither matter nor even light can escape
we're told in terms of density imagine
the Earth shrunk to a diameter of 2 cm
yet somehow kju even survives this final
insane trump card he explains that the
curse technique anti-gravity system was
engraved in yuji's mom through laps he
was able to avoid the restrictions on
unstable output and activation Time by
using his own body as a domain he took a
gamble he says it could have blown up
the whole world but Tan's barrier and
Yuki's will suppressed it so he has them
to thank for surviving pretty insane
stuff and so Yuki the special Gra who
gave Toto his scar during one of her
harsh training sessions was defeated but
man did she ever prove why she deserved
to be a special grade while also letting
Kaku show his immense power too although
she died in this epic battle her memory
lives on and whenever we see Toto scar
we can use it as a reminder of her and
how badass she was right to the end next
we got a look at special great sorcerer
UTA otu Jujutsu Kaizen zero is where we
see his introduction he actually begs ra
the cursed spirit that haunts and
protects him to to not hurt the bullies
that are bothering him but she doesn't
care and wrecks them that's why you
shouldn't bully right there also when
Utah tries to hurt himself she steps in
to protect him we'll later get into how
he's actually the reason she still
haunts him Gojo is actually the one that
originally told him that the curse
attach to him can help people depending
on how it's used and he has to learn to
control its power when his fellow
students meet UTA for the first time
they are shocked by Ra's presence and
quickly back off from him when ra moves
in to protect we see UTA and Ra's back
story where they were kids in love she
gave him an engagement ring for his
birthday she then gets hit by a car to
Utah's shock but that doesn't stop the
promise of marriage and being together
forever the girl lives on as a curse
keeping that promise from long ago the
funniest thing though is when they hear
this story the other students are like
oh so that's all it is he's cursed by ra
the girl who loves him when they're on a
mission at first Maki is shocked to see
that UTA is already a special grade
because of how he seems so worried and
scared all the time she thinks thinks
that it's a joke finally though when
they get eaten by a curse everyone
inside is suffering from being cursed
except UTA who has a resistance to
curses UTA steps up he asks ra to lend
him her strength and she does the other
curse is wrecked and UT and the others
escape go even says freaky so this is
the true identity of special grade vual
Cur Spirit ra orimoto women sure are
scary he adds after the event UTA
recalls that he told ra they'll be
together forever and ever and he starts
to think for the first first time that
it's not ra cursing him but he that's
cursing ra and Gojo says he's always
believed that love manifests the most
distorted curses in all this time like
with Yuji Gojo is the one who is trying
to keep UTA from being executed he even
says that in case of an execution he's
on uta's side to the hups eventually
Gojo gives UTA a katana so that he can
channel the curse of RA into it and
control it at first UTA is weak in
hand-to-hand combat but he keeps
practicing on one Mission with inum
together they defeat a curse without
unleashing ra and ghetto who's behind
the incident Witnesses it and is
disappointed saying too bad I was hoping
I'd get to see the famous ra showing
just how big of a deal ra and thus uta's
power are Gojo then tells III not to be
sorry for how things played out because
the someone who cast another curtain on
top of his and who ensured an
unidentified semi- grade one curse was
there was too strong he knows it's
ghetto who at this point is one of the
four special grades in his considered
the worst of all curse users we'll be
getting into him again later on the
video but for now we're told he was
expelled from Jutsu high and has ended
over 100 civilians at this point ghetto
has already adopted his kill all non
Sorcerers View and tries to get UTA to
join him because he appreciates his
fantastic power as he calls it obviously
UTA refuses to join him and there's
fascinating stuff here which we'll
Circle back to about ghetto as well the
dude appears in front of Gojo and his
students and when Gojo tells him he's
not not leaving he summons a curse and
says all your precious students are
within my range so goo can't even try to
stop him someone being so confident in
declaring war in front of Gojo even a
younger Gojo is truly crazy and Hypes up
ghetto as well ghetto knows he doesn't
have much chance of winning the war
especially if the Jutsu Society gets
involved but he thinks so highly of RA
that he thinks if he kills UTA and takes
the special grade ra as his own curse
Spirit his chances of winning go up to
99% he believes that if he kills the
master mean meaning UTA he can absorb
the curse meaning ra so he plans to
isolate UT and Strikes where he and Maki
are Gojo figures out what's happening in
s inumaki and Panda to help it's not
long though before ghetto takes down
Maki inumaki and Panda UTA sees this and
flips out unleashing ra during the fight
ghetto a curse expert gives ra the title
queen of curses showing how much he
respects her and her power she's even
referred to as a spirit of endless
cursed energy UTA shows how gifted he is
when he uses inum maki's Advanced cursed
speech technique pass down from
generation to generation although to be
fair he does find it hard to use and it
doesn't help him much here at one point
he reinforces his fist and delivers a
brutal and also satisfying punch to
ghetto mug face even ghetto has to say
not bad ghetto mentions it's a good
thing that he came to kill him before
UTA learn to use ra properly ghetto
summons a special grade curse and
combines his 4,461 curses into one using
curse manipulation technique maximum
Uzumaki UTA commits to R and kisses her
monstrous form which Hypes her up the
power of this weird love is enough to
leave ghetto badly hurt he's Amazed by
this power that can change the world and
says if only I had ra I wouldn't have to
collect all of these curses he couldn't
succeed this time but says next time
she'll be his and that's when goo
appears it's revealed that goo purposely
sent inumaki and Panda there knowing
ghetto would defeat them and that that
would trigger uta's growth Gojo also
knew that someone who put jiujitsu
sorcerers on a pedestal like ghetto
wouldn't kill young Sorcerers without
reason so it's not quite as messed up as
it seems at first Gojo then proceeds to
end his former best friend ghetto back
to Utah and goo points out that the ra
curse is broken goo looked into Utah's
lineage he is actually a descendant of
michan sugara meaning although distant
the two Gojo and UTA are relatives so
Gojo says UTA was right Raa wasn't
cursing him he was cursing her he
refused to let her die the cursor severs
the bond tying the ser to the master and
if the cursed doesn't desire punishment
which ra wouldn't then the curse breaks
Ra's Spirit actually thanks UTA for
giving her time and letting her be by
his side she says she's been happier
these past six years than when she was
alive a crazy claim to be sure her
spirit then disintegrates telling him
not to come over to the other side too
soon but never fear even if his L soul
is at peace and the curse that bound
them together is broken UTA keeps his
fighting partner the powerful r round as
we'll see but on to the main story
during chapter 11 Gojo Hypes up UTA
saying he's great along with third-year
hakar and says they'll be as good as him
one day no small cou from the world's
strongest sorcerer and one who knows
just how great he is then it was
suggested that during the 2017 Goodwill
event it was one-sided simply because
Utah and R dominated then when Gojo
confronted Kaku during chapter 90 goo
points out how before he killed ghetto
he was beaten up by Utah UTA is praised
for his ability to unconditionally copy
cursed techniques and his boundless
cursed energy although Kaku personally
thinks that UTA can't become the next
Gojo that doesn't mean he's right and
Gojo like I said with his ego wouldn't
say someone could match him in power one
day just willy-nilly so then UTA finally
makes his main story debut with a splash
when he rescues a girl from a curse when
he's talking to her the curse attacks
him from behind only for ra to take care
of it instantly leaving nothing there
but a wall of splattered blood then he
says he'll kill itadori himself when he
finally comes face to face with Yuji
Yuji thinks it's Gojo at first and then
says no it's something even creepier
definitely High Praise again for this
dude Yuji comments that he's fast even
while holding a drawn Katana UT remarks
that he's got even more cursed energy
than Gojo Sensei albeit he does clarify
that Sensei has the six eyes so the
energy that's lost when he activates a
curse technique is infinitism close to
zero he does admit that Gojo is the best
and that Gojo doesn't run out of cursed
energy while UT can despite this Yuji
notices that uta's whole body including
his Katana is constantly surging with
cursed energy rather than being focused
on one body part making his attacks
difficult to read and it also means his
attacks can be decisive and he can
restrict all damage to a minimum it's
clear that although Yuji lasts for
decently long UTA is in control of the
fight and when Yuji blocks his Katana
UTA simply says he's too focused on his
Katana and kicks him in the gut yui yui
for his part can't help but think that
even a forward kick from UT is
incredibly powerful UT lands a slash on
yuji's body but props to Yuji for
successfully breaking UT's Katana UTA
thinks to himself that it's not
surprising since Yuji is Gojo's pupil so
it was never going to be easy and just
when Yuji thinks he has a chance because
they're both unarmed ra finally steps in
grabbing hold of his head UTA actually
holds ra back by saying they're just
playing while Yuji realizes he can't
move ra is too strong UTA asks to hold
Yuji for him and he stabs Yuji with his
broken off Katana he then apologizes to
him so it's pretty funny how this whole
time UTA wasn't even using his strongest
ability namely ra and he could have if
he really wanted to ended it at any
point as we'll see even physically he
could have been holding back when he
shows up to Cho's fight he quickly
dispatches him with a number of
extremely quick punches while NAA was on
the ropes UTA took choso out without
even making it look like he's trying he
then heals NAA with his reverse curse
technique so that he can inform the
superiors of itad dori's death of course
this was all an act and UTA actually
saved Yuji Yuji later wakes up and UTA
reveals that Gojo had asked him to look
out for Yuji and this was his way of
doing it Gojo pretty much trusted UT to
take care of all the current first and
seconde students except Haka the even
hyper and crazier thing was that UTA did
actually kill Yuji he had to because he
entered a binding vow but he used his
aforementioned reverse curse technique
at the time that his heart stopped he
instantaneously healed him with revers
cursed technique not many people know
UTA can do this so he got away with
being appointed as yuji's executioner
when asked why UTA is doing this he
simply says because Yuji is important to
people who are important to him it's
clear that Utah also views Yuji as more
innocent than himself because while UTA
actually created his own situation as we
saw he says that yuji's power was really
forced upon him during the calling games
UTA is again praised for his cursed
energy which is called bottomless and
for R's strength as well UTA also
proclaims that he will be the one who
will kill Kaku as he faces the creepy
Kuro rushi the special grade cockroach
curse Spirit UTA Nerfs himself in
multiple ways at first by limiting
himself to not using reverse curse
technique or ra who is helping to
protect everyone at the stadium however
he finds himself in a situation where he
has to use reverse curse technique to
finish the special grade off and does so
UTA then faces off against the
reincarnated and very skilled Sorcerers
takako uro and Ryu ishi ishii for his
part compliments UTA for how he supports
his toughness with cursed energy so that
it feels like he's knocking against a
massive water tank eventually the two
think UTA is reaching his limit but
that's when UTA calls back ra and asks
her to give him everything she's got
it's pointed out that ra is his cursed
technique and can store cursed energy
for him the manga also spells it out to
us that while connected to ra through
his ring the following is possible
cursed technique use Ra's complete
manifestation and cursed energy Supply F
from ra at this point in the story he
can maintain a sustained connection for
5 minutes he uses cursed speech to tell
uro not to move and then he punches her
from one side while ra punches her from
the other following that Raa turns to
isori whose technique gets easily
deflected by Raa and isori thinks to
himself that ra might be even tougher
than UTA while dealing with uro it said
that uta's curse technique is copied all
UTA and the reincarnated Sorcerers use
domain expansion at the same time
although they get broken down we end up
in a situation where Kur ri's child and
successor is present along with uro and
isori isori though attacks the other two
wanting UTA for himself he's one of
those overpowered opponents that gets
hungry for a challenge they attack each
other with directed high output blasts
of cursed energy which UTA can do when
ra is manifested P.S it's also revealed
that this ra contains the last remnants
of Ra's human will so that is why this
ra quote unquote weapon still acts like
the first R 2 even if it's not exactly
the same thing or arguably as strong as
it was before anyways after the blasts
cancel each other out UTA avoids another
by using udo's curse technique as has
been established he can copy curse
techniques and I'm just waiting for him
to copy Gojo's one day he then uses ur's
thin ice barrier attack to attack again
props to isori who is still fighting and
even delivers a single blow that was
even too much for the fully manifested
reca the two keep up physical combat but
then UTA throws him to the ground and
isigi gets hit by his own curse
technique which UTA redirected with uro
technique ishigo being the boss he is is
defeated with a smile thanking UTA for
filling his hunger for battle although
credit must be given to isori for
pushing UTA and this version of RA so
far ultimately UTA gets the win again
showing his own skill and prowess which
will only grow from here as pointed out
by Gojo he also needed to keep his
opponents alive so he could have them
transfer points to him so on some level
he was arguably holding back as well
given uta's seemingly bottomless cursed
energy his Improvement of its use over
time and his ability to add overpowered
curse techniques to his tool belt along
the way like curse speech and Sky
manipulation there is really no telling
how strong he can become especially
considering he's only 17 years old right
now and Gojo for his part felt like he
was strong enough to take a serious
punch from him and UTA did although it
did end up making him want to puke now
it's finally time to discuss the one
dubb the strongest and the hypest
character of the series satu Gojo but
first what does a special grade like
Gojo like hitting even more than strong
opponents why the Subscribe button of
course so here's your chance to join a
special grade fan by doing just that if
you haven't already but now back to Gojo
and of course satoru is the strongest
jutu sorcerer in the world there's no
debating that and the man who could
singlehandedly destroy Humanity season 2
of the Jutsu kaai in anime is finally
giving us some insight into Gojo's
insane backstory Satur Gojo was born on
December 7th 1989 and he is such a
menace that after his birth the balance
of power in the entire jiujitsu world
shifted gojou was the first person 400
years to be born with both the power of
Limitless and the power of the six eyes
and this was such a big deal that it
resulted in curses becoming stronger
after his birth basically the good guys
became so overpowered thanks to the
appearance of Gojo that curses started
getting stronger in order to compensate
I repeat Gojo's birth literally threw
the balance of the universe out of whack
and the universe had to start making
curses stronger in order to make up for
it if that doesn't tell you how power
Gojo truly is especially as an
individual that I don't know what will
Gojo was so powerful that the other
important sorcerer families felt
intimidated by him and they were afraid
that they would lose their own status
because of this one member of the Gojo
family being so powerful these other
families went so far as to put out a hit
on him while he was still a kid but all
the bounty hunters who tried to kill him
failed and goo was able to develop into
the charismatic Powerhouse that he is
today in fact Gojo is widely considered
to be the strongest jutu Sorcerer of the
modern era and if you ask Gojo he
believes himself to be the strongest
Sorcerer of any era according to Gojo's
character profile in the first volume of
the manga he can do anything that he
sets out to do essentially making the
impossible possible when he feels like
it on several occasions he has stated
that at full power he could defeat even
the legendary suku in his prime Gojo is
so strong that if technology ran on
cursed energy rather than gas or
electricity Gojo would apparently have
the ability to power an entire large
Nation like the United States on his own
his powers are so great that they could
pose a threat to the whole world if they
ever ended up in the wrong hands ghetto
has stated in the past that Gojo could
potentially destroy all of humanity so
let's just be glad that he's one of the
good guys on our side even though the
Gojo family is one of the big three
sorcerer families along with the zenin
and C families satu is literally the
only known member of the Gojo family sat
is the head of the Gojo family but as I
just mentioned he also seems to be the
only noteworthy sorcerer in the current
generation of the family and yet because
he is so powerful he just kind of solo
carries the entire family name and keep
keeps them at the top of the food chain
the Gojo Clan is originally descended
from Mizan sugara one of the big three
vengeful Spirits from the hayan period
of Japanese history and a legend in the
Jujutsu world but there have been many
Gojo Clan Sorcerers in the past so what
makes satoru Gojo in particular so
powerful and why is he so special as a
member of the Gojo bloodline satoru
inherited the prestigious Gojo Clan
technique known as Limitless this curse
technique brings a concept of infinity
into the physical world allowing its
user to distort and manipulate space in
its base or neutral state which is known
as Infinity Limitless has the ability to
stop anything and everything including
enemy attacks although technically the
technique doesn't stop things it just
slows down their movements to such an
extent that they may as well have been
effectively stopped let me try to
explain it more clearly using the very
Paradox that goou himself references
when talking about his power the Paradox
of Achilles and the Tortoise the F Greek
hero Achilles is challenged to erace by
a common tortoise the slow moving
tortoise says is that it can outrun the
great Achilles as long as it is given a
bit of a head start Achilles believes
himself to be the fastest man in the
world and there is no way that he could
lose to something as slow as a tortoise
so he accepts The Challenge and the race
begins with a tortois having a 100 meter
Head Start Achilles rushes forward
determined to overtake the tortoise he
quickly covers the distance of 100 m and
reaches the point where the tortoise had
begun the race but by that time the
tortoise managed to move 10 m forward
Achilles then runs another 10 m to reach
the position where the tortoise was but
by the time he arrives the taurise has
moved another meter by the time Achilles
moves again to the location where the
tauris was the tauris has moved slightly
forward again and so on and so on in the
end Achilles never catches up because
there's always an increasingly small gap
between him and the Tortoise but it's a
gap nonetheless here's another way to
think about it let's say you want to
walk from One Tree to another in order
to reach the second tree you will need
to reach the half point of the two trees
and then the half point between that
point and the second tree and then the
halfway point between that new halfway
point and the tree and so on infinitely
if you you keep dividing the remaining
distance in half you will never arrive
at your destination and at some point
you will be moving so slow that it will
look like you're not moving at all this
is a mathematical Paradox also known as
xenos Paradox in mathematics no matter
how many times you divide a number it
will never go down to zero it will keep
going down to smaller and smaller
fractions infinitely but never to actual
zero in the real world if you want to
walk from One Tree to another you will
easily arrive at that destination you
won't start infinitely dividing the
distance You cover in half you're just
going to cover the distance so this is a
theoretical and mathematical Paradox not
something that occurs in everyday life
however Limitless actually brings this
mathematical Paradox into reality which
is really cool so if something like an
enemy attack tries to approach the user
of Limitless in this case Gojo it will
never reach him Limitless transforms the
finite amount of space between the
attacker and Gojo into Infinite Space
the enemy attack will never make contact
with Gojo because its distance from Gojo
will just keep dividing itself
infinitely the attacker becomes a killes
and Gojo becomes the tortoise Limitless
so powerful not only because it prevents
enemy attacks from making contact with
goo but also because Gojo can expand the
invisible infinite barrier that
Limitless generates in order to
completely neutralize enemy techniques
and overpower them outright and if that
wasn't enough there are multiple other
techniques that Limitless allows goo to
perform Beyond just Infinity but before
we get into the Epic details of these
other overpower techniques let's quickly
talk about Gojo's other incredible
inherited technique six eyes six eyes is
an ocular Jutsu and this ocular Jutsu
allows its user to detect cursed energy
and see the flow of it as well as to
instantly analyze his opponent's curse
techniques on top of that six eyes
allows its user to have unbelievable
precise control of their cursed energy
right down to an atomic level ensuring
that the user of six eyes virtually
never runs out of cursed energy because
they are able to use it so incredibly
efficiently basically six eyes allows
Gojo to use so little cursed energy that
he never runs out because he recovers it
faster than he can spend it his supply
of cursed energy is not actually
infinite both UTA and sukuna have more
cursed energy than Gojo overall but
Gojo's efficiency in how he uses it
makes it practically infinite six eyes
are essentially the perfect technique
for mastering and unlocking the full
potential Limitless and it is this
unique combination of Limitless and six
eyes that make Gojo the strongest
Sorcerer of the modern era six eyes are
so rare that no two people can possess
them at the same time and as I mentioned
earlier it's been 400 years since a
single person possessed both six eyes
and Limitless a user of six eyes has
visual Powers Beyond those of any other
sorcerer Gojo can literally see through
a blindfold without a problem and he can
easily see what's happening several
kilometers away in fact the reason why
Gojo uses a blindfold in the first place
is to avoid overly straining his eyes
because six eyes is a power that is
always on and it cannot be deactivated
in chapter 71 the sorcerer killer toi
figuro mentioned that he once want to
see the legendary satoru Gojo back when
Gojo was still a kid and Gojo was the
only person who was ever able to detect
toi's presence even while toi was
standing behind him okay so now that
we've established what the six eyes
power is let's talk about all the ways
that Gojo combines six eyes in Limitless
in order to bring out the full potential
of both techniques in absolutely
spectacular ways first let's talk about
blue also known as curse technique laps
blue if Infinity is the base form of
Limitless then blue is its strength and
form and it is activated when Gojo
amplifies the amount of cursed energy
that he is pouring into the the
technique blue allows the user to bring
more theoretical mathematical Concepts
into reality this time the concepts of
negative numbers and negative distance
basically Gojo uses Limitless to create
negative space and then normal space
immediately begins to compensate by
drawing everything towards the negative
space in order to fill it this allows
Gojo to pull people and objects toward
that space at great speed similarly to
the way a huge magnet works this
technique can be used with less
intensity in order to pull in targets
towards each other and the same effect
can even be used to make the user move
at high speeds by pulling himself so
quickly towards a specific destination
that it appears as if he is teleporting
Gojo's ability to use blue as a means of
Transport enabled him to become one of
the fastest Sorcerers in history however
the technique can also be used with more
intensity to pull apart entire buildings
in an instant or to completely destroy
the bodies of enemies blue is a
technique that is very difficult to use
because it requires a lot of cursed
energy and it requires that energy to be
used in an extremely precise way way
luckily for Gojo the six eyes allows him
to do exactly that next let's talk about
red also known as reverse Limitless red
Gojo uses the positive energy that comes
from his reverse curse technique to
reverse the effects of blue rather than
attracting objects and people like blue
does red repels them if blue is like two
opposite charged magnets that are
attracted to each other then red is like
two similarly charged magnets repelling
each other Gojo produces a small red orb
on the tip of his finger and when the
power of the orb is released it
generates a mass massive shock wave that
blows everything within the surrounding
area away from Gojo Red's cursed energy
output is said to be at least twice the
cursed energy output of blue which
increases the potential for collateral
damage since red requires the use of
reverse curse technique and since only a
small number of sourcers in history have
been able to use this technique go is
one of the only people to be able to use
this technique in the history of the
world and even he had to work hard in
order to learn to use it it actually
took a near-death experience for him to
finally figure it out and if you thought
that red and blue were badass then wait
until I tell you about super secret
Fusion technique called Hollow technique
purple purple is created through the
merging of blue and red when the two
opposite Powers Collide an imaginary
mass is produced and this Mass has the
ability to essentially erase everything
in its path out of existence purple
neither attracts nor repels it produces
a purple energy ball that simply
annihilates everything it touches the
existence of this technique is such a
closely guarded secret that members of
the other prominent families such as the
zening clan don't even know it it exists
and thus they have no effective counter
to it as it should be clear by now all
of Gojo's powers are insanely rare and
impressive including six eyes Limitless
itself and the various techniques
derived from Limitless such as red blue
and purple but we can't end the
discussion on Gojo's power without
talking about his greatest power of all
Gojo's domain expansion called unlimited
void unlimited void allows Gojo to bring
himself in his Target or targets inside
of the Limitless itself as the name
suggests the area within Limitless is an
unlimited void that contains an infinite
amount of knowledge and information in
fact when a Target is forced to enter
unlimited void their mind is immediately
bombarded with endless information to
the point of overwhelming them and
rendering them completely immobile the
user and anyone he touches directly is
immune from the effect but the user's
intended target will essentially lose
their mind and eventually die if Gojo
doesn't deactivate the power the effect
of unlimited void is so powerful that if
a non sorcerer is exposed to it for more
than 0.2 seconds they will suffer
lasting consequences and death in those
0.2 seconds an entire 6 months worth of
information floods into the target's
mind rendering them unconscious and
afterwards they will require like 2
months of therapy just to get back to
normal although Gojo's Limitless and its
techniques are among the most powerful
abilities in Jutsu kaisa and quite
possibly they could be the single
strongest power when taken as a whole
there are some ways that exceptionally
strong opponents of Gojo can attempt to
counter his techniques Limitless can be
countered by other exceptionally
powerful domain expansions or domain
amplification and there are some curse
tools infused with specialized curse
techniques that can interfere with the
power of Limitless but believe it or not
Limitless and six eyes are not even the
only powers in Gojo's vast Arsenal Gojo
is extremely strong and fast physically
as well he has incredible endurance and
he is an expert in hand-to-hand combat
Gojo is also very tactical and a master
strategist and these important abilities
are of course boosted by the six eyes
allowing Gojo to develop superhuman
observational and analytical skills Gojo
is also capable of producing many other
techniques including black flash curtain
simple domain and falling Blossom em
motion falling blossom in motion is
actually a secret technique passed down
within the big three sorcerer families
that serves as a countermeasure against
the domain expansion of your opponent
this technique can either nullify a
domain's attack entirely or it can
reduce the damage suffered by the user
in case their opponent's domain is
incredibly strong new Shadow style
simple domain also allows Gojo to
counter enemy domains by neutralizing
the can't miss attacks of the domain in
question Gojo doesn't normally need to
use this technique and he only uses it
against the most powerful opponents
finally it is important to emphasize
that Gojo's Mastery of reverse curse
technique also sets him apart from other
sorcerers not only can he use this
technique virtually continuously in
order to heal his physical body in
perpetuity but Gojo could also use
reverse curse technique to recover his
burnt out curse technique after using
domain expansion allowing him to create
multiple domain expansions within the
span of only a few minutes we can't
forget that the vast majority of
sorcerers who have a domain can only use
it like once a day top so this is a huge
deal and after learning all all of that
about goo spectacular powers and
abilities I don't think I need to tell
you how dangerous these Powers would be
if they got into the wrong hands if for
whatever reason goo turned bad like his
buddy ghetto or if he lost control of
his body in some way the entire world
would be absolutely screwed like imagine
sukuna in Gojo's body and how insane
that would be during the infamous
Shibuya incident kenju and the other
villains managed to seal Gojo inside
prison realm a special grade cursed
object that contains living barriers
constructed with the final remains of
the Buddhist monk gen the barrier has
the ability to seal anything or anyone
including Gojo Gojo spends 19 days
sealed inside the object and then he is
successfully unsealed by his allies the
unsealing takes place in chapter 221 of
the manga and this scene in which Gojo
is unsealed tells us a lot about just
how dangerous Gojo could potentially
become while preparing to unseal Gojo
Yuji shoko hakari Angel and the others
realized that because physical time
doesn't flow in the prison realm there
is no way to tell how goo actually
experienced the time he spent sealed
away it might have been just a few
moments for him or it might have felt
like he was alone for hundreds of years
everyone is worried about what Gojo's
State of Mind might be like upon the
release and as shoko points out
depending on his mental state it could
actually be dangerous to unseal him in a
confined space so they decide to unseal
Gojo inside an abandoned mind in the
middle of nowhere in order to avoid any
potential destruction to the surrounding
area upon Gojo's release and even though
goo is ultimately fine upon his release
and he just rushes to confront ghetto
right away the preparations that his
allies take before they release him
confirm the fact that Gojo has the
potential to be extremely dangerous like
I've been alluding to if goo was ever to
become psychologically imbalanced in any
way or if he was to somehow get
possessed by Kaku or manipulated in some
other way he would become a massive
threat not just for the small community
of Jutsu Sorcerers but for all of Japan
and the entire world Gojo being Gojo not
only did his confinement inside the
prison realm not unnerve him but it
actually made him stronger by teaching
him how to create an an extremely small
domain a domain that is so dense and
refined that it is actually smaller than
the size of a basketball this insane
durability and adaptability is what we
love about goo but it's crazy to think
about just how screwed up the world
would be if goo ever turned to the dark
side most recently Gojo has been leading
in a fight against sukuna and even
managed to knock him out sukuna said
himself he's as good as full power and
he even needed to take over megumi's
body to use mahaga just have a chance
currently although godra appears to have
knocked out sukuna with black flash he
now has to deal with a mahura that has
adapted to his powers but it appears
like Gojo was right when he said he'd be
able to beat sukura in his prime
especially one without mahaga abilities
and finally let's discuss Gojo's best
friend ghetto the man whose body would
be taken over by kinjaku now there will
be some overlap here because literally
Ghetto Life overlaps with every other
special grade sorcerer's Life as we saw
and since we discussed ghetto in passing
during the explanations of the other
special great characters we can just
summarize the important bits here as we
saw the dude experienced a 180 whereas
before Gojo was the one saying it's a
pain to look out for the weak and ghetto
was saying Society should protect the
weak and keep the strong in check ghetto
is the one who ended up wanting to
eliminate the weak non Sorcerers who
create curses his ability to catch and
release cursed Spirits including special
grade cursed Spirits like their Pokemon
is called cursed Spirit manipulation he
used this overpowered ability so well
that goo at the time considered himself
and ghetto to be the strongest but as is
hilariously revealed when a shikigami
user tries to take him on close range
ghetto is also very good at close combat
and deals with him effortlessly later
goo reveals how much he trusts in ghetto
abilities ghetto is worried about goo's
state after the latter went so long
without sleep and goo says he's good and
besides you're here too he says to
ghetto however both of them didn't see
toi coming toi even beats the previous
version of Gojo before his Evolution to
a stronger fighter who can use reverse
cursed energy and his now signature red
and purple attacks so it's not
surprising that ghetto didn't stand a
chance either in fact toi only spared
him because he wasn't sure what would
happen with his curses if he died and he
wanted to avoid unnecessary trouble
during this fight ghetto unleashed the
rainbow dragon a curse that's supposed
to have the toughest hide there is but
toi cuts through it like it's nothing by
the time Jutsu Kaa in chapter zero
happens ghetto is older eviler and
stronger but not strong enough despite
being one of the strongest which seems
to be a recurring problem for him he's
introduced as one of the special grades
and specifically like I said before as
the one who is considered the worst of
all curse users we're told that he was
expelled from Jutsu high school and that
he's killed more than 100 civilians not
good stuff to be known for so clearly
he's no longer the guy who says that
jiujitsu is for protecting non Sorcerers
at this point he even insults non
Sorcerers by calling them monkeys ghetto
plans to destroy Jutsu high so they
won't stand in his way but before that
he introduces himself to Utah Maki and
the rest they can't help but notice how
fast he is he talks about his goal of
killing all non Sorcerers and realizing
a world with only jiutu sorcerers he
declares war and when goo says he won't
let him get away with it ghetto responds
that he shouldn't even try it since all
of Gojo's precious students are within
his range once again it's impressive
that he could declare war in front of
Gojo and just get away with it ghetto
planned to kill UTA and take ra the
queen of curses as he called her he
easily deals with Maki Panda inumaki
against UTA he releases one of his
special grade curses tamamo noay
incarnate he also releases his most
powerful attack Maxim Uzumaki he tells
UT it's a good thing he came to kill him
before UT learned to use his power but
all of his curses combined weren't
powerful enough and UTA and ra won out
once again later ghetto points out that
God purposly let all this unfold to
trigger uta's growth while godo blurs
the line between good guys and bad guys
when he said that he knew ghetto
wouldn't kill a young sorcerer without
reason he knew that his students were
safe since ghetto doesn't just want to
cause suffering but to create a world
for Jutsu Sorcerers and so he obviously
wouldn't kill them unless it's
absolutely necessary even if they do
fight him and then kinjaku picks ghetto
body to take take over because of the
potential of his cursed Spirit
manipulation however we can't really
consider what Kaku does or how well he
does in future fights to be the same as
ghetto so gto's Own Story stops here
after all kinjaku beat Yuki but only
because he had access to the curse
technique anti-gravity which was
ingrained in ki itadori it perfectly
countered Yuki's overpowered black hole
attack that even cost her her own life
however ghetto would not have had access
to this ability and so would have been
finished if Yuki even had to take it
this far against ghetto as an opponent
so now with that in mind let's get into
the rankings I think it's pretty clear
for me that ghetto is the weakest he was
weaker than the strongest sorcerer Gojo
even before Gojo got his already
mentioned significant power up he lost
to Utah and ra when Utah was much less
experienced than he is now and kenjac
who only survived against Yuki because
he had the power that ghetto wouldn't
have had access to then I got to go with
Yuki in third place who made quite the
impression and does have an insane
potential for getting at least a tie
against even the strongest of opponents
on by creating a black hole but she's
gone now as far as we know UTA for his
part has been hyped up for so long was
able to beat ghetto as an inexperienced
kid and Gojo even said that he has the
potential to be as good as him which he
didn't say about Yuki yes ra the queen
of curses helped Utah beat ghetto but as
we know now he created that queen of
curses in the first place which again
just goes to Hype up his own power and
future potential and last but definitely
not least we got goo in first place as
the strongest special grade sorcerer
it's been said many times throughout the
series in this video and should come as
no surprise when someone just lasts long
against him like sukuna did recently
it's considered a massive feat which
just goes to show how strong this Legend
is considered to be not even sukuna the
king of curses dared to challenge him
with his own strength alone knowing he'd
have to rely on mahaga if he'd have any
chance of winning now cheating or not if
you want to know more about this dude
who may end up taking down Gojo one way
or another the strongest sorcerer ever
then check out our recent video about
and why everyone is afraid of him link
on screen right now make sure to like
And subscribe to join the special grade
fam and I'll see you there